wir kommen nun zu dem geschäftsbereich
des bundesministeriums für umwelt
naturschutz
nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz ich bitte zügig die
plätze zu wechseln also nun kommen wir
wie ich angekündigt zum etat von
bundesumweltministerin steffi lemke sie
kümmert sich um die angesprochenen
punkte da geht es zum beispiel um die
zwischenlagerung und endlagerung
radioaktiver abfälle aber auch um die
nukleare sicherheit den strahlenschutz
aber zum beispiel auch um die tier und
pflanzenarten
natürlich er möchte sie verhindern dass
das artensterben weitergeht eine million
tier und pflanzenarten sind vom
aussterben bedroht
eigentlich wollten dort die
un-staaten sich dafür einsetzen dass
dieses artensterben zumindest
verlangsamt wird mit einem
rahmenabkommen mit 21 erzielen sollte
dafür gesorgt werden dass bis zum jahr
20 30 etwa 30 prozent aller meeres und
landflächen geschützt werden aber nun
schon jetzt bevor überhaupt dieses
rahmenabkommen
verabschiedet wurde das soll nämlich
erst im sommer verabschiedet werden ist
jetzt schon gibt es jetzt schon
anzeichen dass diese zahl etwas so
optimistisch ist wegen der korona
pandemie und wesen des krieges in der
ukraine
steffi lemke wird also sich mit diesen
themen auseinandersetzen aber eben auch
und mit der bedrohung dass durch die
weltlage sie nicht so schnell voran
gehen kann wie wahrscheinlich gewünscht
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren abgeordnete wenn wir
heute den haushalt des
bundesumweltministeriums
beraten dann geschieht das unter dem
eindruck einer geopolitischen
zeitenwende die korona krise ist noch
lange nicht überstanden
da sind wir durch den angriffskrieg
russlands auf die ukraine bereits mit
einer neuen um ein vielfaches
dramatischeren krise konfrontiert
unsere vordringlichste aufgabe ist es
jetzt selbstverständlich den menschen in
der ukraine zu helfen denen zu helfen
die auf der flucht sind und diesen krieg
zu beenden ist selbstverständlich die
kernaufgabe der diplomatischen
anstrengungen der bundesregierung und
der gegen russland verhängten sanktionen
wir stehen vor existenziellen
herausforderungen die uns vor augen
führen wie verletzlich unsere
gesellschaft unser wirtschaftssystem wie
abhängig unsere versorgungsstrukturen
von einem aggressor wie herrn putin
gemacht worden sind dieser krieg
verlagert kurzfristig natürlich auch den
fokus weg von anderen krisen aber der
völlig falsche ansatz wäre es jetzt die
ökologischen fragen zurückzustellen
die klimakrise und dass arten aussterben
sind eben auch zwei krisen die
existenziell für die menschheit sind und
so sehr wir uns jetzt um das heute
kümmern müssen so sehr müssen wir dabei
das morgen im blick behalten die antwort
auf den angriffskrieg russlands kann
nicht lauten deutschland verringert
seine abhängigkeit von importen aus
russland und gibt aber dafür seine pläne
auf ganz grundsätzlich unabhängig von
importierter kohle öl und gas zu werden
die antwort kann nicht lauten wir werfen
klima und naturschutz ziele über bord
und riskieren damit die stabilität
unserer natürlichen lebensgrundlagen
und die antwort kann eben auch nicht
lauten wir steigen wieder ein in die
atomkraft die fürchterlichen geschehen
ist die ukraine machen einmal mehr
deutlich wie riskant unsere technologie
ist und wie sehr sie uns ebenfalls
abhängig macht von importen sei es eben
aus russland oder aus anderen ländern
und um dies an dieser stelle auch noch
einmal auszuführen
der betrieb der jetzt noch am netz
befindlichen drei reaktoren ließe sich
eben nur strecken um circa drei monate
nach hinten verschieben ohne dass in
summe mehr strom überhaupt produziert
würde aber natürlich zusätzliche risiken
damit verbunden wären
sicherheitsüberprüfungen et cetera
verbunden werden und anderenfalls wenn
man mehr als diesen kleinen beitrag
erzielen wollte müsste man eben neu
einsteigen in die beschaffung von
brennelemente in wirklich umfangreiche
sicherheitsprüfungen und dies in zeiten
wo die ukraine und europa zu recht mit
riesen großer sorge auf einen krieg rund
um atomanlagen schauen und es geht eben
nicht zu suggerieren man könnte das
einfach ein bisschen länger laufen
lassen als würde man nachts das licht im
flur brennen lassen wir reden hier über
eine hochrisikotechnologie und wer den
einstieg wieder einstieg in diese
technologie
diskutieren möchte in unserer
gesellschaft der sollte den menschen
wenigstens reinen wein einschenken
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren wir
stehen vor einer richtungsentscheidung
im umgang mit diesen gleichzeitig
stattfindenden krisen lösen die uns aus
abhängigkeiten betreiben wir vorsorge
sind sicherheit stabilität und sozialer
ausgleich das was unsere gesellschaft
jetzt zusammenhält und sind wir bereit
dafür auch relevante veränderungen in
unseren gesellschaften in unseren konsum
und in der produktion anzustoßen oder
verharren wir halten in der hoffnung so
doch irgendwie noch eine weile über die
runden zu kommen meine antwort ist klar
gerade jetzt müssen wir begrenzte
finanzielle ressourcen effizient nutzen
für klimaschutz und energie souveränität
für naturschutz und gesundheitsschutz
für kreislaufwirtschaft und weniger
abhängigkeit von knappen ressourcen
damit
damit stabilisieren wir unsere
wirtschaft und wir reduzieren
abhängigkeiten und wir schützen unsere
natürlichen lebensgrundlagen ich will in
der hand von vier beispielen erläutern
welche schwerpunkte das bmf auch im
haushalt dafür setzt mein erster punkt
der klimaschutz der massive ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien ist essenziell um
unsere abhängigkeit von importierten
erdgas öl kohle und uran zu beenden und
diese ausbauen muss aber im einklang mit
dem naturschutz erfolgen robert habeck
und ich werden dazu bis ostern geeignete
vorschläge vorlegen ein alten
hilfsprogramm dass artenschutz die vom
ausbau der erneuerbaren besonders
betroffen sind wird hierzu einen beitrag
leisten
neben den erneuerbaren energien sind
wälder und böden moore und auch in
wichtige natürliche klimaschützer die
zugleich unseren wasserhaushalt
stabilisieren und sichern ich werde in
der nächsten woche eckpunkte für das
bundesprogramm natürlicher klimaschutz
vorlegen und ich habe mich im
haushaltsentwurf erfolgreich dafür
eingesetzt dass dieses programm mit
ausreichenden finanzmitteln aus dem
klima- und transformations- form
ausgestattet wird und ich hoffe dass das
parlament diesen entwurf unterstützt
ein zweites beispiel vor sorge vor den
folgen der klimakrise
der jüngste bericht des weltklimarates
beschreibt wirklich schonungslos die
auswirkungen der klimakrise die wir auch
hier in deutschland in mitteleuropa
immer stärker zu spüren bekommen die
notwendigkeit zur anpassung und vorsorge
wird sich weiter verschärfen
mit jedem zehntelgrad erhitzung das bsv
agiert hier gemeinsam mit ländern und
kommunen diese genauso wie lokale
akteurinnen und akteure soziale
einrichtungen und soziale einrichtungen
wird das bav besser unterstützen für
klima anpassungsmaßnahmen dafür haben
wir die bisherigen modellprojekten in
einen regelprogramm überführt besser
ausgestattet und werden beratung und
kompetenz aufbau für die anpassung an
die klimakrise damit unterstützen
drittes kreislaufwirtschaft wir alle
wünschen uns in der aktuellen
geopolitischen krise eine stärkere
autonomie von importierter energie und
ressourcen diesem ziel dient eine
zeitgemäße kreislaufwirtschaft mit
geschlossenen stoffkreisläufen mit
klugen product design ermöglicht die
wertschöpfung und sichert zugleich
unsere lebensgrundlagen wir werden
wichtige schritte raus aus der
wegwerfgesellschaft gehen zum beispiel
durch ein recht auf reparatur
gleichzeitig werden wir dafür ein
förderprogramm reparieren statt
wegwerfen auflegen und die
bundesregierung wird sich auch bei der
g7 präsidentschaft mit einem schwerpunkt
der ressourceneffizienz und für weniger
primär ressourcen einsetzen
lassen sie mich in diesem zusammenhang
auch die vermittlung unserer meere mit
plastik ansprechen die welt umwelt
versammlung in nairobi hat anfang des
monats die verhandlungen für ein
rechtlich verbindliches abkommen
gegen die plastik verhüllung angestoßen
das ist ein großer erfolg für den sich
deutschlands seit vielen jahren
eingesetzt hat und es ist ein großer
erfolg für den multilateralismus und es
macht gerade in diesen zeiten
tatsächlich mut
mein letztes beispiel der naturschutz
spätestens seit der korona pandemie ist
uns bewusst dass die zerstörung von
natur und der direkte kontakt mit
wildtieren das risiko dass
krankheitserreger von wildtieren auf
menschen überspringen massiv erhöht im
extremfall bis hin zu einer pandemie und
damit ist naturschutz gleichzeitig auch
pandemievorsorge
erfolgreicher naturschutz steht und
fällt mit seiner finanzierung der
regierungsentwurf sieht daher vor die
mittel für den naturschutz gegenüber der
finanzplanung erheblich aufzustocken und
in einem neuen bundes naturschutz form
zu bündeln mit über eine halbe milliarde
euro sind für diesen fonds in den
nächsten vier jahren mehr finanzmittel
vorgesehen als je zuvor
sehr geehrte damen und herren der
meeresschutz gehört dort natürlich auch
mit dazu auch dieser ist im haushalt
abgebildet und ich möchte zum schluss
ausführen lösungen die wir im umwelt-
und naturschutz vorschlagen helfen uns
gegen multiple krisen sie verhungern ab
verringern abhängigkeiten von ressourcen
stabilisieren unsere natürlichen
lebensgrundlagen und vermindern
gesundheitsrisiken und technologische
risiken krisen und lösungsansätze dürfen
nicht gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
sie müssen gemeinsam angegangen
und mit diesem grundgedanken bitte ich
sie um unterstützung für den
vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf für das
bundesministerium für umwelt vielen dank
irgendwas und
steffi lemke hat hier auch verschiedene
schwerpunkte ihrer arbeit aufmerksam
gemacht die sie plant und auch noch
einmal dafür gewarnt das auto
csu-fraktion zuge der diskussion um die
energiesicherheit die klima- und
naturschutz ziele nicht aufgegeben
werden sollen sehr anja weisgerber jetzt
für die uhr zurück zügen und kollegen
das wort budget basiert auf dem
altfranzösischen
begriff bouquet und das bedeutet
lederbeutel in diesem führten die
menschen früher ihr geld mit und so ein
lederbeutel ist entweder mit vielen
münzen oder mit wenigen münzen gefüllt
um im bild zu bleiben der lederbeutel
des bundesministeriums für umwelt und
verbraucherschutz ist etwas leerer als
im vergangenen jahr das hat auch mit den
neuen zuständigkeiten des hauses zu tun
damals wie heute müssen die menschen
entscheiden was sie mit diesen münzen im
lederbeutel mit dem geld das sie zur
verfügung haben machen wo möchten sie
investieren wo sind die schwerpunkte und
wie ist die reihenfolge der prioritäten
in ein paar punkten stimmt die union mit
der von frau ministerin aufgezeigten
prioritäten über einen einigen nicht und
dabei kommt es auch sein oder andere mal
auf die umsetzung und auf die
ausgestaltung an meiner rede gehe ich
auf zwei unserer schwerpunkte 1 die
klimaanpassung und die
kreislaufwirtschaft in verbindung mit
dem verbraucherschutz zum thema klima
anpassung fakt ist der menschengemachte
klimawandel findet statt auch bei uns in
deutschland
das mussten wir im vergangenen jahr in
teilen von nordrhein westfalen
andernfalls und auch in bayern auf
besonders leidvolle weise erleben ganze
existenzen wurden binnen weniger stunden
zerstört die schäden gehen in
milliarden-höhe menschen wurden verletzt
und manche menschen haben auch ihr leben
verloren deshalb ist die klimaanpassung
in all ihren facetten
ein wesentlicher pfeiler des
klimaschutzes das haben wir auch in der
letzten legislaturperiode auch gegenüber
dem damaligen koalitionspartner immer
wieder zum ausdruck gebracht und liebe
ampel regierung ich muss ihnen ein lob
aussprechen denn sie haben in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag mit der ankündigung
einer klima anpassungsstrategie und
eines klima anpassung des gesetzes einen
zentralen punkt unseres
unions-wahlprogramm es aufgegriffen
neben den beiden sollen
soforthilfen und wiederaufbau muss auch
die klima vorsorge dabei eine ganz
prominente rolle spielen wir müssen
dafür sorgen und sicherstellen dass in
zukunft die schäden an mensch tier
umwelt und infrastruktur gar nicht
entstehen durch prävention und durch
klimaanpassung die liebe ampel müssen
jetzt zeigen dass sie es ernst meinen
mit ihrer klima anpassungsstrategie
indem sie entsprechende finanzielle
mittel zur verfügung stellen und die
anpassungsstrategie auch mit leben
füllen andernfalls wird dieses prestige
projekt in ihrem ressort frau ministerin
wie eine seifenblase zerplatzen das
wollen wir nicht denn das thema klima
anpassungen der schutz von mensch natur
und umwelt ist uns wirklich auch sehr
wichtig meine damen und herren
ein zweiter schwerpunkt von cdu und csu
ist die kreislaufwirtschaft in
verbindung mit dem verbraucherschutz
deutschland ist ein rohstoffarmes land
und deshalb müssen wir die rohstoffe und
materialien die wir einmal im eigenen
land haben immer wieder nutzen und wir
müssen die kreislaufwirtschaft immer
weiter stärken gerade der
völkerrechtswidrigen krieg in der
ukraine zeigt uns wie abhängig
deutschland immer noch von
rohstoffimporten ist die neue politische
situation hat vieles verändert und wir
müssen jetzt die konsequenzen ziehen die
rohstoffe die wir nutzen kommen aus drei
quellen aus importen aus der nutzung
eigener nationaler rohstoffvorkommen und
der nutzung von sekundärrohstoffen
klar ist dass deutschland als
industrienationen auch künftig nicht
ohne rohstoffimporte aus kommen wird
aber wir müssen diese importe so weit es
geht eben substituieren und da ist auch
die effizienz beim rohstoffeinsatz
besonders wichtig die müssen wir
steigern produkte sollten deshalb auch
so hergestellt werden dass ihr
reparierbar sind und länger haltbar
deshalb sagen wir das von der
bundesregierung geplante recht auf
reparatur werden wir auch im sinne eines
nachhaltigen
verbraucherschutzes kritisch begleiten
nachhaltig ist es aber nur wenn es den
verbrauchern und der umwelt am ende
wirklich etwas nutzt und wenn es auch
für die unternehmen machbar ist dies
umzusetzen und als ehemalige
europaabgeordnete ich das auch betonen
wir müssen beobachten was die
europäische union bei dem punkt macht
für sie eventuell schon auf europäischer
ebene ein recht auf reparatur ein die
antwort auf diese fragen muss die basis
sein für die entscheidung auf nationaler
ebene zu dem thema und frau ministerin
ich sage ihnen noch eins einen neuen
preistreiber der der umwelt und den
menschen unter dem strich nichts nutzt
und auch einen nationalen alleingang und
überregulierung das brauchen wir
definitiv nicht und da werden wir auch
den finger in die wunde legen meine
damen und herren
[Applaus]
der kern der substitution von rohstoffen
ist die kreislaufwirtschaft wir müssen
wir stärke sie muss die tragende säule
der rohstoffversorgung unseres landes
werden das möchte ich noch einmal
betonen aber frau ministerin dafür
müssen wir auch die rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen
weiterentwickeln und da gehört es auch
zur wahrheit dass wir bestehende
hemmnisse abbauen müssen stoff recht
chemikalienrecht lebensmittelrecht bis
hin zur normung müssen überprüft werden
denn sekundärrohstoffe sind keine
abfälle es sind wertstoffe deshalb
müssen wir die schadstoffgrenzwerte auch
so ansetzen dass sekundärrohstoffe nicht
als abfälle eingestuft werden sondern
eben als rohstoffe weiter genutzt werden
müssen auch da muss die ampel regierung
zeigen dass es mit der
kreislaufwirtschaft wirklich ernst meint
meine damen und herren
der rechtliche rahmen ist das eine zur
weiterentwicklung der
kreislaufwirtschaft zählen auch
innovationen und es sind investitionen
erforderlich stichworte sind neue
technologien bei der sortierung und
aufbereitung der abfälle wie zum
beispiel auch die weiterentwicklung des
chemischen recyclings
kreislaufwirtschaft ist umweltschutz auf
der einen seite und es ist gleichzeitig
eine chance für unsere wirtschaft
circulo economy wirklich auch die
rohstoffe in unserem land zu halten und
wieder zu nutzen nutzen wir diese chance
auf nationaler ebene und
kreislaufwirtschaft hat auch eine
internationale dimension sie haben es
angesprochen uns alle erfüllt die
zunehmende vermüllung der weltmeere mit
sorge und jacke ministeriums ist ein
erfolg dass auf der umwelt versammlung
der vereinten nationen in europa anfang
märz ein mandat für die verhandlung
eines internationalen abkommens gegen
die vermüllung erteilt wurde aber wir
müssen jetzt haben und deswegen frau
ministerin bin ich sicher dass wir mit
ihrer hilfe auch die erforderlichen
einsparmöglichkeiten dafür finden dass
die entwicklungsländer beim aufbau von
abfall zu sammeln systemen und
sozialsystemen stärker unterstützen auch
dafür muss platz in diesem haushalt sein
herzlichen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
anja weisgerber aus der unionsfraktion
hat hier vor einem nationalen alleingang
gewann aber auch vor der überforderung
der wirtschaft und von privatpersonen
wenn es cds
videothek spricht der
sozialwerke hätte frau präsidentin der
geehrte damen und herren kolleginnen und
kollegen der brutale und durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen angriffskrieg gegen die
menschen in der ukraine machte schwer
eine haushaltsdebatte zu führen wo es ja
oft auch um trockene zahlen geht ein
lichtblick den wir alle zur zeit erleben
in den wahlkreisen ist die
hilfsbereitschaft der bevölkerung die
flüchtlinge aufnimmt und versucht ihm
mut zu geben in einer zeit der
zerstörung und bedrohung ihrer heimat
vielen dank an alle die sich hier oft
ehrenamtlich einsetzen die tun eine
wichtige arbeit und wir werden auch geld
für kommunen bereitstellen müssen und
dann werden eben die zahlen zu konkreten
projekten die den menschen helfen über
diese schwierige zeit hinweg zu kommen
und so liebe kolleginnen kollegen ist
auch mit dem einzelplan 16 dem umwelt
haushalt den schutz unserer umwelt das
ist ein drängendes problem und wird von
der mehrheit auch zunehmend zur
wahrgenommen auch wenn es jetzt manchmal
aktuell in den hintergrund getreten ist
letzte woche war der umweltkommissar
sinkiewicz es aus litauen zu gast im
bundestag und hat uns berichtet dass es
bereits erste stimmung stimmung stimmen
in der eu gibt die die aussetzung des
küchenteams wollen weil es jetzt
wichtigere dinge gebe das ist
grundfalsch und kurzsichtig und so sah
es auch der umweltkommissar
der schutz unserer umwelt bedeutet
sicherheit im wandel und wir schaffen
innovationen im umwelt- und
ressourcenschutz geschützen für uns und
für nachfolgegeneration natürliche
lebensräume und wir sichern die zukunft
mit maßnahmen im natürlichen klimaschutz
der krieg in der ukraine macht es uns
schmerzhaft deutlich wie wichtig es ist
dass deutschland von fossilen
brennstoffen unabhängig wird aber es
gilt eben nicht nur für die fossilen
brennstoffe sondern auch für andere
rohstoffe
deshalb müssen wir unsere wirtschaft zur
kreislaufwirtschaft umbauen nur so
können wir erreichen dass unsere
heimische wirtschaft generell
unabhängiger wird von rohstoffimporten
und zunehmend auch sekundärrohstoffe
nutzen kann
ein wichtiges beispiel ist für eine
nachhaltige verkehrspolitik die
batterieproduktion
2030 wird sich die nachfrage nach
batterien gegenüber 2018 voraussichtlich
verzehnfacht haben das wiederum setzt
zwingend voraus dass wir batterien
hochwertig recycelt
denn viele der rohstoffe die wir zur
produktion der leistungsstarken lithium
ionen akkus benötigen werden unter
ökologisch und sozial schwierigen
bedingungen abgebaut nickel zum beispiel
kommt zum großen teil auch aus russland
hier müssen wir unabhängiger werden von
import von rohstoffen um unsere
wirtschaft resilient zu machen also
stabiler gegenüber schwanken den
lieferketten in krisenzeiten um die
umwelt zu schützen und eben auch die
natürlichen lebensräume zu erhalten die
durch den rohstoffabbau oft
unwiederbringlich zerstört werden viele
neuerungen im bereich des umweltschutzes
in der kreislaufwirtschaft wurden und
das kann ich nicht ersparen frau weiß
geben in den letzten jahren abgelehnt
oder abgeschwächt weil man die
wirtschaft nicht noch zusätzlich
belasten wurde dass wir häufig eben das
argument das ist eine sträfliche
innovationsfeindlich
verhinderungspolitik ich habe darauf
immer wieder hingewiesen
wir brauchen vorgaben und finanzielle
anreize um schnell voranzukommen wir
haben schon zu viel zeit verloren hier
unabhängige unserer wirtschaft von
rohstoffimporten ist umso stärker ist
deshalb ist die kreislaufwirtschaft wie
ich hier bundestag schon oft und immer
wieder erwähnt habe nicht nur gelebter
umweltschutz sondern wie ist auch die
grundlage für eine nachhaltige
innovative wirtschaft in deutschland
hierzu gehört auch das klare bekenntnis
zur bekämpfung von illegalen abfall
exporten es ist eine schande wenn einige
immer noch glauben sich ungestraft hier
schnell bereichern zu können und
gleichzeitig wichtige stoffströme unser
land verlassen
obwohl wir sie hier hochwertig recycelt
können und wieder bereitstellen können
jede investition in die greift der
wirtschaft das nachhaltig und effizient
weil die mehrfach wirbt für den
umweltschutz für den klimaschutz und für
eine nachhaltige wirtschaft für den
haushalt des bundesministeriums für
umwelt naturschutz und nukleare
sicherheit und verbraucherschutz sind im
zweiten regierungsentwurf 2022 insgesamt
rund 2,2 milliarden euro vorgesehen der
einzelplan hat sich insbesondere was den
klimaschutz angeht durch den neuen
ressortzuschnitt geändert aber erhalten
ist eben ein ganz wichtiger punkt und
dass die anpassung an den klimawandel
die herausforderung werden hier ständig
wachsen denn die veränderten
klimabedingungen sind schon längst
weltweit aber natürlich auch in
deutschland spürbar kommunen haben
bereits heute mit wasserknappheit und
hitzeperioden zu kämpfen menschen in
sozialen einrichtungen krankenhäusern
und altenheimen bisschen verstärkt wir
hierzu geschützt werden und der schutz
von hochwasser und starkregen
ereignissen stellt uns immer wieder vor
neue herausforderungen
im einzelplan des umweltministeriums ist
für die förderung der maßnahmen
anpassung an den klimawandel ein auf
fuchs von rund 37 millionen euro auf
rund 60 millionen euro für 2022
vorgesehen das ist wie ich meine mehr
als gerechtfertigt
dazu kommen ausgaben für den natürlichen
klimaschutz dieser titel ist erstmal
eine wirtschaftsplan zum energie- und
klimafonds er wird durch das bfv
bewirtschaftet und für ihn sind in den
jahren 2022 bis 26 ausgaben in der höhe
von insgesamt 4 milliarden euro
vorgesehen
mit diesen geldern sollen synergie
zwischen natur und klimaschutz genutzt
werden die renaturierung die
wiederherstellung von ökosystemen wie zb
[ __ ] tragen aktiv und nachhaltig zum
klimaschutz beiden wie auch in den
letzten jahren sind die größten posten
im einzelplan 16 die ausgaben für die
zwischen- und endlagerung des atommülls
der bund trägt die verantwortung für die
finanzierung und durchführung der
zwischen entladungen sowie der standort
auswahlverfahren
hierfür sind im jahr 2022 rund insgesamt
1,1 milliarden euro vorgesehen wir geben
also die hälfte des gesamten umwelt aus
umwelt haushaltes für die folgen der
nutzung der atomenergie aus und hier
wird spät ist es noch mal deutlich der
atomenergie ist weder sicher noch
günstig und eine weiternutzung das hat
ja die frau ministerin für mich
hervorragend ausgeführt ist auf keinen
fall sinnvoll
insbesondere
besonders wichtige umwelthaus aus meiner
sicht die aufstockung und ausweitung des
förderprogramms gegen die vermüllung
konkret geht es beim letzten um die
aufstockung der förderung des exports
von technologien gegen die vermüllung
unserer weltmeere hier sind im
vorliegenden regierungsentwurf
verpflichtungsermächtigung für die
nächsten jahre in höhe von 25,5
millionen euro vorgesehen für diese
förderprogramme ist tatsächlich schon
seit jahren ein ziel ist es die
abfallmenge direkt an der quelle durch
funktionierende sammle logistik und
recycling und der songs verfahren zu
reduzieren so dass der plastikmüll gar
nicht erst in die weltmeere gelangen
kann dazu werden in ländern und regionen
in asien und afrika
die den größten eintrag vom meeres milch
produzieren funktionieren der abfall und
kreislauf management systeme aufgebaut
und weiterentwickelt
die projekte sollen zu einem weltweiten
netzwerk von leuchtturmprojekten werden
die zusammenarbeiten und in ihrer
jeweiligen region als multiplikatoren
agieren je mehr mittel werden dieses
programm stecken desto mehr projekte
können wir fördern um so schneller
können wir den eintrag von plastikmüll
in die weltmeere reduzieren einen der
ganz großen umweltprobleme in unserer
zeit
der ein oder andere kennt es sicherlich
aus seinem wahlkreis das sind die repair
cafés also da wo wirklich geräte
repariert werden und eben nicht zu
werden deswegen freue ich mich über das
förderprogramm reparieren statt
wegwerfen ein ganz wichtiger schritt und
man kann sagen hier gerade bei diesem
programm werden die belange des
verbraucherschutzes und die probleme des
umweltschutzes umgesetzt und das
programm ist im besten sinne kann man
sagen nachhaltig ganz im sinne des
verbraucherschutzes sind aber auch
unsere ansätze der kreislaufwirtschaft
die schon bei der herstellung der
produkte einsetzen also bei
langlebigkeit transparent was die
lebensdauer angeht reparieren fähigkeit
oder recycelbarkeit fühlte ich mich
ebenfalls intensiv einsetzen werde in
den nächsten wochen wird es natürlich
auch noch weitere befassung mit dem
regierungsentwurf geben ich freue mich
auf die weiteren diskussionen mit ihnen
es geht eben nicht nur um trockene
zahlen sondern es geht auch darum die
vorhandenen mittel effizient und
nachhaltig einzusetzen für den erhalt
unserer erde für den schutz dieser und
kommender generationen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der abgeordnete wolfgang
wille für die fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen umweltschutz
die bewahrung der natürlichen
lebensgrundlagen ist ja nur
konservatives anliegen
kommt diese aufgabe aber in die hände
von ideologien sind die lebensgrundlagen
schnell auf der verliererstraße
wenn eine regierung versucht die
energieversorgung eines ganzen landes
fast ausschließlich auf riesige
windräder und gewaltige solarparks
umzustellen hat das notwendigerweise
starke auswirkungen auf die natürlichen
lebensgrundlagen in meiner bayerischen
heimat erlebe ich wie nun in größen und
bislang unverbauten waldgebieten
gewaltige windräder geplant werden diese
dinger haben mit 50 meter
betonfundamente die möglicherweise nie
wieder aus dem waldboden
es wäre aufgabe des umweltministeriums
solche aspekte verschärft in den blick
zu nehmen allein bei den derzeitigen
politischen prioritäten von rot grün
gelb charts dürfte diese dringende
forderung eine forderung der bürger
bleiben ohne politische und setzen
in diesem land wird eben wie das wall
street journal hellsichtig erkannt hat
die dümmste energiepolitik der wertige
verfolgt auch unser nachbarland belgien
führt gerade vor wie sehr deutschland
als energiepolitische geisterfahrt
daherkommt belgien verschiebt einen
atomausstieg um zehn jahre
während die bundesregierung wir haben es
gerade wieder gehört halsstarrig daran
festhält
aus dem haushaltsentwurf für das
umweltministerium
spricht an vielen stellen ebenfalls eine
sap syrische arroganz bei einigen titeln
etwa den forschungsausgaben für den
umweltschutz wird lapidar festgestellt
mehr wegen erhöhtem bedarf der dativ ist
dem genitiv sein tod die
politische aussage dieser versuchten
begründung ist aber viel schlimmer als
die grammatik sie ist für den bundestag
eine beleidigung sie bedeutet ja nicht
mehr als wir brauchen mehr weil wir mehr
brauchen
mehr geld wird auch an
nichtregierungsorganisationen
ausgeschüttet 5 millionen euro wollen
genau dieselben leute die die ganze zeit
vom klimawandel und von mehr stürmen
reden nun dem bauhaus der erde schicken
und dieser verein wirbt für das bauen
mit holz das ist schon eine sehr
spezielle art von politischer juni
apropos holz das umweltbundesamt das
ebenfalls mit mehr geld bedacht werden
sollen sollte sich mal auf andere dinge
konzentrieren als auch das verbot von
holzfeuerungen in einer zeit in der
vielleicht bald das gas fährt und auch
die stromversorgung nicht mehr sicher
ist sollten die bürger fürs heizen auf
einheimische nachwachsende rohstoffe
zurückgreifen können
oder heißt das programm wir frieren für
die freiheit für messen freiheit
eigentlich die bürger werden das anders
eingespart wird dann auch mal
aber an der völlig falschen stelle die
zuschüsse für die stiftung warentest
werden zusammengestrichen die immer die
wirtschaftliche realität der bürger
ihrem handeln unterstützt hat ist das
nun die strafe dafür dass die stiftung
beim test von fb zwei masken für kinder
rückgrat bewiesen hat und kein einziges
produkt empfohlen hat
es gibt meine damen und herren also
genügend stoff um den einzelplan 16
kritisch unter die lupe zu nehmen die
fdp fraktion wird sich engagiert an der
beratung in den ausschüssen betrag will
da
das sagt wolfgang wiehl hier für die fw
fraktion sitzt er im haushaltsausschuss
in diesem ausschuss dessen mitglieder ja
insgesamt in dieser langen plenarwoche
was der haushaltsberatung 1 belassen der
sehr gefordert sind
auch für die fdp-fraktion der nächste
redner das ist für mich klar
frau präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen laut
aristoteles sind es vor allem zwei dinge
die die fürsorge und zuneigung der
menschen auf sich ziehen das eigentum
und das was man liebt das besitzer etwas
besitzt gibt darauf 8 ist eine ressource
endlich wird man entweder nach methoden
suchen sie wieder zu verwerten oder sie
sparsam einzusetzen
eigentum ist ein zentraler eckpfeiler
marktwirtschaftliche ordnung ein
weiteres ist das prinzip der achtung
auch dies trägt dazu bei das miteigentum
verantwortungsvoll umgegangen wird denn
wer zur rechenschaft gezogen werden kann
wird umsichtig agieren um fehler zu
vermeiden
dieses diese beiden prinzipien stärken
auch den umweltschutz
sind die eigentumsverhältnisse unklar
kümmert sich keiner kann keiner zur
verantwortung gezogen werden wenn es
schief geht ja dann ist das eine
gesellschaftsform die privates eigentum
nicht kennt und diskriminiert sie ist
also unfrei sondern und schadet auch
natur und umwelt sie sie vollzieht
aufbau nicht ohne grund sind die größten
umweltschäden in ländern des sozialismus
zu finden eine marktwirtschaftliche
ordnung sitzt den rahmen für eine faire
und lebenswerte gesellschaft in der die
kräfte verantwortlich handeln können wir
sehen heute engagierte unternehmen die
über gesetzliche standards hinausgehen
weil sie investitionen in umweltschutz
als wettbewerbsvorteil ergreifen laut
des statistischen bundesamtes haben sich
die umweltschutz investition im
verarbeitenden gewerbe in deutschland
von 2009 bis 2019 mehr als verdoppelt
auf fast 12 milliarden euro
die ampel koalition unterstützt diese
entwicklung bereits in diesem jahr sind
mit über einer milliarde mehr als die
hälfte der ausgaben im einzel platz 16
für investitionen vorgeschlagen
zudem werden bis 2026 im umwelt und
verbraucherschutz insgesamt 113
milliarden mehr ausgegeben
die garantie von rechtssicherheit
privateigentum vertragsfreiheit und
freie preisbildung wird diese
entwicklung begleiten und unterstützen
hier setzt auch der verbraucherschutz an
zur unterstützung der mündigkeit der
bürger wollen wir nicht nur innovation
und medienkompetenz stärker in den fokus
rücken auch die finanzkompetenz sowie
die resilienz überschuldete verbraucher
soll eine größere rolle als bisher
spielen am ende setzen wir auf den
mündigen verbraucher
mit einer sachorientierten
umweltpolitischen gesetzgebung und der
förderung einer lebendigen innovativen
start up kultur bekommt menschliche
erfindergeist die
entfaltungsmöglichkeiten die er braucht
unser ziel muss es sein dass wir alle
über sämtliche grenzen hinweg von
innovativen
innovation profitieren die heute noch
illusorisch wirken nur so können auch
ungewöhnliche ideen zur marktreife
werden
hier reden wir nicht nur sondern wir
handeln auch für 2022 sind im einzel an
16 über 150 millionen euro für bildung
und forschung vorgesehen das entspricht
einer steigerung zum ist wer 2021 um
sage und schreibe 50 prozent und das
auch aus gutem grund wir brauchen
forschung wissenschaft innovation und
die vielen klugen ideen der menschen nur
immer bessere und neue technologien
ermöglichen uns energie bezahlbar
umzuwandeln und gleichzeitig die natur
und auch das klima zu schützen
es darf in der umwelt und energiepolitik
keine denkverbote geben
der schreckliche kleine krieg und unsere
abhängigkeit von russischem erdgas die
wegen des massiven ausbaus der
erneuerbaren noch gestiegen ist zeigt
dies überdeutlich
auch bei der lösung von komplexen
umweltproblemen brauchen wir die
kreativität der vielen und der
wettbewerb der besten ideen
moralpredigten über veränderungen des
individuellen lebensstils weg vom auto
zum fahrrad vom fleisch zu pflanzenkost
von der plastiktüte zum jutebeutel sind
eben nicht zielführend sie sind
letztendlich individuellen
lebensentscheidungen die wir nicht
eingreifen dürfen es braucht kreativität
und wettbewerb und ökonomen jeglicher
couleur zeigen uns empirisch bereits
seit jahrzehnten dass man bei negativen
externen effekte nötigen falls ein mit
markt etablieren müssen also seltenheit
wettbewerb und ein preis nur so kann man
kann es uns gelingen heimische
umweltschutztechnologie zum
exportschlager zu machen auf dem weg der
verbote und des moralischen zeigefingers
wird uns niemand folgen auf den
der wirtschaftlichen fortschritt eine
freie lebensweise und effektive
ressourcen schonung verbindet allerdings
schon
in der deutschen umweltpolitik wurde in
der vergangenheit viel zu viel zu
kleinteilige diskussionen geführt dies
war über bürokrat schon meist abhängig
von einzelinteressen und einzelne
entscheidungen oftmals formulierten wir
kalzium ambitionierte ziele die
regelmäßig verschärft werden schließlich
verkommen diese ziele und maßnahmen
jedoch zum papiertiger und her praxis
wird nichts erreicht gleichzeitig
erkennen wir dass das heil auch aber
nicht nur im klimaschutz liegt
meine damen und herren in diesem bereich
müssen wir vorhandene konzepte endlich
entschlossen umsetzen und innovative
innovative lösungen weiter entwickeln
unser ziel müssen lebenswerten
naturlandschaften sein der sich noch
nachfolgender generationen wohlfühlen
und frei entfalten und in dieser
einsatzplan hätten sehr rege sich 21
vielen dank frau präsidentin täten das
aber sonst auf kosten ihrer kollegen
olibet sp präsidentin petra pau die
macht natürlich hier über die redezeit
bei so einer langen sitzungswoche und
solchen langen sitzungstage der
einzelplan für das ministerium umwelt
naturschutz nuklearer sich ein
verbraucherschutz ist ja eine der
kleineren 1 im pläne in relation gesehen
im haushalt ist 2,19 milliarden euro im
juli im vergleich zur arbeit und
soziales 160 milliarden ergibt sich
diese relation nächste rednerin ihr
tamira momentan die fraktionsvorsitzende
in berlin hin kolleginnen und kollegen
gerade einmal 41 millionen euro sind im
haushalt für die verbraucherpolitik
vorgesehen zum vergleich ein unternehmen
das auch bezahlt wird für deutsche
unternehmen im ausland werbung zu machen
bekommt 44 millionen euro mehr also als
für den schutz von 83 millionen
verbraucher verbrauchen anderen land
vorgesehen sind kolleginnen und kollegen
das geht so nicht verbraucherschutz
braucht
denn viel zu oft werden verbraucher von
großen unternehmen betrogen und
abgezockt überhöhte dispozinsen
kreditverträge mit hoher enten
versteckte nebenkosten irreführende
werbung kürzlich warnte die
verbraucherzentrale nordrhein westfalen
alle großen telefonanbieter ab der
geschlechter beratung wegen verstößen
gegen informationspflichten und jeder
der schon einmal in einer der vielen
kunden hotlines festsaß der weiß viel zu
oft braucht man nerven wie drahtseile
als verbraucher zu seinem recht zu
kommen aber das sollte nicht so sein
der blick in die digitale welt zeigt den
ernst der lage umso deutlicher es
wimmelt von fake bewertungen fake shops
unsere daten werden viel zu oft
hemmungslos genutzt der manipulator
manipulation sind tür und tor geöffnet
und nicht jedem ist bewusst dass die
algorithmen die das individuelle kauf
von klickverhalten analysieren nicht nur
für individuelle produkt angebote sorgen
nein sie sorgen auch für
individualisierte preisen aus der
füllung von persönlicher von
persönlichen daten wird analysiert wer
von uns bereit ist für welches produkt
wie viel geld auszugeben und den preis
kriegt man dann angezeigt das ist
manipulation auf allerhöchstem niveau
und all den muss man etwas
schlagkräftiges entgegensetzen kollegen
die verbraucherschützer in unserem land
zum beispiel die verbraucherzentralen
die arbeiten unermüdlich mit großartigem
einsatz
aber dieser übermacht können sie viel zu
oft viel zu wenig entgegensetzen weil
sie personell und sachlich einfach nicht
genug ausgestattet sind geben sie ihn
endlich die mittel die sie brauchen um
ihre wichtige aufgabe zu erfüllen
schluss mit dieser unterfinanzierung und
das gilt auch für sämtliche
staatliche kontrollbehörden von der
lebensmittelaufsicht bis zum 2 kürzlich
habe ich bei mir zu hause in oldenburg
ein gespräch geführt mit zollbeamten und
ich weiß nicht ob die bundes regierung
weiss wie die lage der ist darum stelle
ich mal kurz da die
technische ausstattung ist wenn
vorhanden vollkommen überein digitale
vernetzung zwischen den behörden ist
mangelhaft die mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter
sind chronisch überlastet weil
kolleginnen und kollegen fehlen und ja
ich weiss es sollen jetzt mehr stellen
beim zoll geschaffen werden das ist auch
gut aber bereits heute können 8 uhr nach
stellen nicht besetzt werden weil man
einfach keine leute dafür findet und das
liegt wiederum daran dass man als
zollbeamter zum einstieg nur so wenig
verdienen dass man dafür nicht mal eine
wohnung einer großstadt bezahlen kann
hier muss man ran es muss insgesamt
endlich schluss damit sein dass
diejenigen inland wie wichtig seine
aufgaben in den kontrollbehörden in den
beratungsstellen im gesamten sozialen
bereich dass diese menschen mies bezahlt
werden und bedauern überlastung leiden
damit muss schluss sein echte leistung
muss sich endlich logan kollegen und
kollegen
und das gilt auch für die
schuldnerberatung ja erstmals sind dafür
im haushalt jetzt eine million
vorgesehen donnerwetter in anbetracht
der wachsenden notwendigkeit von
flächendeckender schuldnerberatung ist
das wirklich nur ein fein wird aufgrund
der steigenden der explodierenden
energiekosten
gegen die sie kolleginnen und kollegen
von der regierung sich nachhaltig weil
effektive maßnahmen zu ergreifen wie zum
beispiel entsprechende steuersenkung
staatliche preisaufsicht wegen dieser
effektiven kosten geraten immer mehr
menschen in ernsthafte schwierigkeiten
gute und kostenlose schuldnerberatung
flächendeckend ist wichtiger denn sie
nach unseren berechnungen bräuchte es
davor 15 millionen euro dauerhaft im
haushalt für eine soziale
schuldnerberatung und das ist wirklich
das mindeste
und wenn es nach uns geht sollten
inkassounternehmen an diesen kosten auch
angemessen beteiligt werden wenn man
bedenkt wie viele sich hier teilweise
mit quer- als fragwürdigen methoden eine
goldene nase verdienen ist das wirklich
nur recht und billig
leider reagiert die neue bundesregierung
bisher mit der gleichen zögerlichkeit
der gleichen knausrigkeit die die
vorgängerregierungen wenn es darum geht
das notwendige geld für beratungsstellen
kontrollinstanzen kontrollbehörden
verfügung zu stellen warum wollen sie
ernsthaft behaupten dafür sei kein geld
da wenn sie auf der anderen seite
unfassbare 100 milliarden euro für
ausrüstung ausgeben wollen sogar das
grundgesetz soll dafür geändert werden
warum es für den verbraucherschutz nur
so wenig geld da frau ministerin lemke
diese frage müssen sie in bürgerinnen
bürgern unseres landes wirklich
beantworten dankeschön und diese frage
gestellt hier in der aussprache hat aber
ihre momentane fraktionsvorsitzender der
linken wie also hat kritisiert nur knapp
41 millionen euro sind 2022 für die
verbraucherpolitik vorgesehen steffi
lemke die bundesumweltministerium hat ja
diesen bereich verbraucherschutz
zugeschlagen bekommt zu ihrem
ministerium in der vergangenen
wahlperiode da war der noch beim
bundesjustizministerium
angesiedelt und jetzt also hier bei
umwelt und naturschutz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir stehen
gerade in diesen tagen vor
existenziellen herausforderungen die uns
vor augen führen wie verletzlich unsere
gesellschaft ist und gerade deshalb
dürfen wir darüber nicht die klimakrise
und das massenhafte aussterben von arten
aus dem blick verlieren die ökologischen
fragen stellen sich mit größter
dringlichkeit
es geht gerade jetzt darum die resilienz
unserer gesellschaft zu erhöhen herr
lindner hat heute morgen ausgeführt und
dafür ist der natürliche klimaschutz
essentiell
intakte ökosysteme sind wichtige
kohlenstoffsenken aber nicht nur das
naturschutzgebiete wie der nationalpark
schwarzwald die für den arterhalt so
wesentlich sind das ist kein luxus
sondern das ist unsere lebensgrundlage
das ist unsere zukunft
wir brauchen aber auch klimaanpassung
ein großteil der emissionen bis 2050
unser leben verändern sind bereits
ausgeschlossen wir wissen und das
regional sehr exakt was auf uns zukommt
und wir müssen den mut haben unsere
augen dafür zu öffnen
berlin könnte und wird wahrscheinlich
2050 das wetter von toulouse haben
winter ohne schnee werden normal die
anzahl an hitzetagen wird sich
verdoppeln und die landwirtschaft in
deutschland muss sich auf regelmäßige
dürren einstellen in der region von
meinem wahlkreis esslingen dürfte sich
die tigermücke ausbreiten und auch auf
solche entwicklungen müssen wir
vorbereitet sein
damit klima anpassungen aber irgendwann
ein ende nehmen können und wir uns die
enormen kosten die langfristig damit
verbunden sind sparen können hat die
neue bundesregierung den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien ganz oben auf die
agenda gesetzt die vorteile einer
sauberen und dezentralen
energieversorgung sind offensichtlicher
denn je auch geostrategisch und wir
werden zeigen dass klima und naturschutz
vereinbar sind
die lebensgrundlage
von arten wie schwarz streichen oder
wanderfalken die vom ausbau der
windkraft ganz besonders betroffen sind
werden wir mit den bundes naturschutz
form verbessern auch den meeresschutz
stärken wäre im ersten
demonstrationsprojekten soll munition
geborgen zerlegt und den schwimmenden
entsorgungsanlagen verbrannt werden
dieses vorhaben zeigt auch wie lang ein
krieg nachwirkt
lassen sie uns jetzt die krisen nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen
so sehr wir uns um das heute kümmern
müssen so sehr müssen wir dabei das
morgen im blick behalten wir brauchen
keinen wohl weg wir brauchen zukunft
[Applaus]
dass jan hörte hat jetzt das foto die
cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kollegen wir alle schauen in die ukraine
und sind entsetzt über den
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg den wir
dort erleben und die konsequenzen dessen
sind international spürbar sind nicht
nur ein drama für die ukraine sondern
sie haben konkrete auswirkungen am ende
auch für uns in deutschland
und wenn wir uns anschauen dann was da
passiert dann hat das frau ministerin am
ende auch ganz konkrete auswirkungen für
ihre arbeit und für das was der
einzelplan 16 jetzt im entwurf eben noch
nicht aufgegriffen hat wir werden sehen
dass die konsequenzen für uns in folgen
haben werden was die energiepreise
angeht was die versorgung mit rohstoffen
angeht vor allem aber auch was die
versorgung und die internationalen
preise an nahrungsmittel angeben und
wenn wir uns etwa die prekäre
gasversorgung anschauen dann sorgen sich
viele verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
aber auch unternehmen über das was auch
in zukunft im blick auf die zapfsäulen
mit blick auf die strom- und gaszähler
oder etwa auf die supermarktregale wenn
wir uns anschauen wie sich die situation
gerade in den letzten wochen monaten
entwickelt hat dann sind wir in einer
situation wo sich preise so dynamisch
entwickelt haben wie wir das bislang
noch nie kanten und die prekäre
gasversorgung wird leider dazu führen
dass wir auch schwarz sehen müssen für
die im blick genommene versorgung und so
aus stromnetzes mit gaskraftwerken zur
netzstabilisierung
wir haben also eine kurzfristige und
auch eine langfristige unterversorgung
mit energie in den blick zu nehmen das
wird am ende arbeitsplätze kosten es
wird wohlstand und einkommen vernichten
olaf scholz hat am sonntag dem 27 januar
von einer zeitenwende gesprochen und er
hat angekündigt dass vieles auf den
prüfstand gestellt werden muss
insbesondere bei der
verteidigungspolitik der die regierung
tragenden parteien
sondern aber aufpassen dass aus dieser
rede am sonntag nicht eine sonntagsrede
wird bei auf den
weil auf den prüfstand müssen wir nicht
nur die verteidigungspolitik und unsere
außen sicherheitspolitik stellen sondern
selbstverständlich auch alle anderen
bereiche insbesondere etwa unsere
energiepolitik wir müssen dafür sorge
tragen dass wir alle nationalen und
europäischen ressourcen heben die uns in
dieser situation weiterhelfen können so
ist doch klar geworden zumindest jetzt
jedem jetzt klar geworden dass bei dem
energie dreieck die
versorgungssicherheit absolute priorität
vor den anderen beiden bereichen
klimafreundlichkeit und bezahlbarkeit
haben und
herr kollege ohne die
versorgungssicherheit nutzen preise gar
nichts nutzt auch klimafreundlichkeit
gar nichts wenn es am ende in
deutschland zappenduster wird priorität
muss ganz klar die versorgungssicherheit
und deswegen ist die aufgabe auch der
regierung das ist eben schon einmal
angeklungen
vorurteilsfrei und ich betone
ausdrücklich frau ministerin auch
ideologiefrei zu prüfen welche
möglichkeiten wir haben politisch
wirtschaftlich aber eben auch
technologisch unseren beitrag zu leisten
dass wir ein stück weit uns besser
aufstellen etwa wenn es darum geht die
kohle und auch die kernkraft weiter zu
nutzen wir müssen prüfen wie es aussieht
mit unseren nationalen öl- und
gasreserven wir müssen frau ministerin
auch prüfen wie es aussieht mit ccs und
cpu und schließlich auch mit dem
ausschöpfen unserer biomasse die wir in
deutschland nutzbar machen aus gutem
grund hat die europäische kommission
jetzt angekündigt in frage zu stellen ob
wir beim green new deals nicht ein teil
der maßnahmen aussetzen um zunächst
alles nutzbar zu machen was in europa
und frau ministerin auch im eigenen land
nutzbar zu machen geht
ich vermisse dieser im haushalt aussagen
zum thema
alternativer mobilitätsformen es gibt
eben nicht nur strom autos sondern wir
müssen auch schauen was sonst geht etwa
bei synthetischen kraftstoffe für eine
lange zeit wird der fuhrpark auch mit
verbrennern ausgestattet sein wir müssen
schauen dass wir auch holz und pellet
nutzung weiter möglichkeit machen und
nicht wie von ihren nachgeordneten
umweltbundesamt angekündigt das
verbieten wollen wir müssen schauen dass
wir
wir müssen schauen
dass wir in der planungs beschleunigung
massiv gas geben so wie es von der
letzten bundesregierung angepackt wurde
um die großen herausforderungen etwa
beim ausbau unseres energie
wirtschaftssystems der erneuerbaren aber
auch der infrastruktur unseren beitrag
zu leisten frau ministerin ihr haus hat
viele aufgaben vorsicht wir als cdu csu
fraktion sind gerne bereit unseren
beitrag zu leisten kritisch aber
konstruktiv
[Applaus]
war das für die cdu/csu-fraktion und
erst mit jedem ausschuss für umwelt
naturschutz nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz die ausschüsse ja
immer spiegelbildlich zu den ministerien
helmut ebert ist der nähe hat also der
umweltausschuss eben auch den
verbraucherschutz zugeschlagen bekommen
wie das ministerium ja in dieser neuen
position
lässt den liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der heutige 22 märz ist nicht nur der
tag der haushaltsdebatte im deutschen
bundestag es ist auch der internationale
tag des wassers im jahr 1992 ausgerufen
von den vereinten nationen wurde das
verbunden mit der vereinten nationen
wasser dekade von 2018 bis 2028 vier
jahre sind bereits verstrichen ziel
dieser aktion ist insbesondere die
wissensverbreitung zum thema wasser und
gewässerschutz es ist die stärkung der
kommunikation zur umsetzung von wasser
bezogenen zielen insbesondere der sts
die deutsche bundesregierung hat schon
in der letzten wahlperiode
diesen aufruf ernst genommen und sowohl
einen nationalen wasser dialog initiiert
als auch einen internationalen wasser
dialog für nachhaltiges wasserressourcen
und gewässermanagement und diesen auch
im letzten jahr abgeschlossen warum sage
ich dass wassermangel wir uns droht wird
uns alle betreffen und ich will das noch
ein klein wenig vertiefen bei den
oberflächengewässern ist das alles für
uns sichtbar kleinere gewässer versiegen
stehende gewässer verlieren insbesondere
wenn sie grundwasser gespeist sind an
volumen
das ganze ist aber noch eigentlich
katastrophaler das global institute for
water security hat daten einer
satellitenmission analysiert und kommt
zu folgendem ergebnis in den letzten 20
jahren hat deutschland in summe
oberflächengewässer feuchtigkeit im
boden grundwasser das volumen eines
bodensees verloren und auch das ist
vielleicht interessant die betroffenheit
ist natürlich nicht gleich verteilt das
betrifft ebenso die lüneburger heide wie
auch mit besonderen schwerpunkt bayern
und wartet baden württemberg
das alles ist nicht nur folge des
klimawandels
natürlich auch wir merken das an
katastrophalen starkregen und
hochwasserereignissen wir merken es an
langen und heftigen dürreperioden die
eine bedrohung für unsere wälder und für
unsere landwirtschaft darstellen gerade
heute hat der berliner tagesspiegel
berichtet dass in den berliner forsten
eichen im besten lebensalter spontan
umfallen und man feststellt dass sie
über keinen wurzelballen mehr verfügen
die ursache ist noch einigermaßen unklar
vermutlich ist es eine kombination aus
wassermangel und schädlingsbefall
es ist auch folge der umgestaltung
unserer flächenversiegelung
trockenlegung blockierte entwässerte
überschwemmungsgebiete moro und
ähnliches und ein steigender
wasserbedarf in wirtschaft und
landwirtschaft
der kollege test hat darauf hingewiesen
dass insbesondere die klimafolgen
anpassung unter natürliche klimaschutz
ein wichtiges element sind eine
zukünftige antwort wird darauf die
nationale wasserstrategie liefern auch
die iss begonnen von unserer damaligen
umweltministerin svenja schulze und ich
freue mich dass die bundesregierung
bereits erklärt hat diese nationale
wasserstrategie weiter zu verfolgen und
zum jahresende die ressort abstimmung
durchgeführt zu haben
im koalitionsvertrag hat die klimafolgen
anpassungen breiten raum eingenommen und
sie korrespondiert natürlich mit dem
natürlichen klimaschutz und der
artenvielfalt das gehört zusammen
insbesondere mit blick auf das wasser
die ziele müssen also sein was er in der
fläche zu halten moritz zu schützen zu
renaturieren wieder zu vernässen owen
wieder herzustellen naturnahe wälder zu
entwickeln und vieles mehr ich erinnere
nur an das blaue band in bezug auf die
bundeswasserstraßen auch das ein
wichtiges projekt das alles führt
zugleich die artenvielfalt das zugleich
fördert den biotop erhalt und die
wiederherstellung von biotopen
deswegen ist es sehr begrüßenswert aus
dass aus dem egf rund vier milliarden
euro über die zeit veranschlagt werden
lauf für das laufende jahr 590 millionen
euro das ist ein richtig dicker brocken
finde ich oder du hast das kommen der ja
ich meine es war dieses jahr 590
millionen euro
zugleich gilt es aber auch wasser
sensible städte zu fördern das ist nicht
vordringliche aufgabe des bundes aber
wer sich das mal anschauen will sie
kennen alle wahrscheinlich noch den
ehemaligen flughafen tegel das dort
entstehende schumacher quartier soll
genau diesen ansprüchen entsprechen ich
will zuletzt noch darauf hinweisen dass
es sich um eine gemeinsame aufgabe von
bund ländern kommunen wasserwirtschaft
landwirtschaft wissenschaft und
forschung aber auch
wohnungsbaugesellschaften usw handelt
wir setzen mit diesem haushalt wichtige
voraussetzungen dafür für den
natürlichen klimaschutz und auch der
bundes naturschutz vor wird einen
wichtigen beitrag des bundes dazu
leisten in diesem sinne bin ich sicher
wir sind gut aufgestellt und es hat der
kollege dennis rohde heute morgen gesagt
lebensbedingungen für zukünftige
generationen gilt es zu sichern dafür
ist dieser haushalt hervorragend
gerüstet vielen dank
[Applaus]
doktor rainer kraft hat das wort für die
afg fraktion
[Applaus]
wird die präsidentin frau ministerin
wehrte kollegen noch niemals ist eine
regierung nach einem frontalzusammenstoß
mit der realität so schnell und so hart
auf dem boden der realität angekommen
wie diese
neben vielen punkten mit etwas
vornehmlich natürlich ihre
energiepolitik und damit die frage nach
der kernkraft und auch die frage nach
den nuklearen reststoffen die eu gibt in
der taxonomie den weg vor ein land nach
dem anderen macht sich auf den weg in
die nukleare zukunft und diese regierung
stellt sich blind und taub
diversifizierung der energiewirtschaft
wäre das gebot der stunde aber diese
regierung des zweiter immer nur auf
erneuerbare und gas gas gas wie ein
süchtiger auf der suche nach dem
nächsten schuss und den nächsten dealer
um der eigenen abhängigkeit zu
entfliehen buckelt man sich dabei in die
nächste und das verhalten wir
selbstverständlich wahrgenommen
internationalen auch von den
gaslieferanten wenn jedes kernkraftwerk
in europa bedeutet weniger verkauft das
gas für ein kernkraftwerk wie sie es in
deutschland haben kann man zirka eine
milliarde kubikmeter gas pro jahr
gegenrechnen es ist daher kein wunder
dass die europäischen absichten sich mit
kernkraft vom gas unabhängiger zu machen
von den gaslieferanten torpediert werden
zum beispiel durch die finanzierung von
anti atomkraft bewegungen von umwelt und
klima verbänden oder auch durch
inszenierte kämpfe auf den geländen von
ukrainischen kernkraftwerken
aber bleiben wir bei den reststoffen der
zivilen nutzung
während ansonsten recycling und
wiederverwendung an höchste priorität
genießen auch jenseits der
wirtschaftlichkeit der projekte hält man
bei den nuklearen reststoffen daran fest
dass man sich das problem ist mittels
eines tiefen loches entledigt
verantwortliche umgang meine damen und
herren ist das nicht und es gibt
zahlreiche es gibt zahlreiche beispiele
aus der vergangenheit zum beispiel das
würde heute angesprochen nach den
weltkriegen hat man viel munition
einfach in nord und ostsee ins meer
geworfen und heute sucht uns dieses
unverantwortliche handeln heim und wir
müssen das wegräumen
das gleiche ist mit der deponierung von
toxischen stoffen über zweieinhalb
millionen tonnen von arsen quecksilber
dioxinhaltigen abfällen schlummern in
deutschen deponien oftmals
oberflächennah ohne halbwertszeit und
oftmals sogar aus dem ausland nach
deutschland
importiert aber das interessiert
niemanden
es wird weiter unheimlich viel
steuergeld verbrannt um sich an den nur
15.000 tonnen reststoffe abzuarbeiten
und an dieser schwerpunktsetzung erkennt
man die widersprüchlichkeit des handels
dieser regierung ein kleineres problem
wird massiv mobilisiert mit
steuerzahlergeld buskosten wird die
entladung vergoldet und andere größere
probleme der deponierung werden
weitestgehend ignoriert das heißt
lebensministerium sie handeln aus
ideologischen gründen mit zweierlei maß
es ist daher nötig auch bei den nokian
reststoffen mit den hinterlassenschaften
verantwortlich umzugehen haben sie auch
zu trennen alles was verwertet werden
kann eine verwertung zuzuführen und den
unwiderruflichen reste einzuladen
schützen sie da eigentlich die umwelt
bestand ihre alten ideale aus dem
letzten jahrhundert hochzeit kollege sie
stärken sie die eine diversifizierung
und helfen sie mit unsere nation den
fängen der autokraten in ost und maus zu
befreien beginnen sie mit dem entzug
kollegin
[Applaus]
judith skudelny hat jetzt das wort für
die fdp fraktion sie ist die sprecherin
für umwelt und verbraucherschutz dr die
liberalen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
putins angriffskrieg hat die
weltpolitische lage verändert ist er hat
die politische lage in deutschland
verändert und sie beeinflusst auch die
politik im umwelt und verbraucherschutz
bereich wer jedoch denkt vor dem neuen
herausforderungen in alte denkweisen zu
verfallen der ist schlicht und
ergreifend falsch beraten die ampel
koalition wird die aktuellen kommenden
fragen mit
pragmatischen und progressiven lösungen
herangehen
ertrinken fragen ist die umwelt umgang
mit der welt ernährungspolitik mit der
welternährung 30 prozent der
getreideernte wird durch die
beeinflussung des krieges weltweit
ausfallen das sind auswirkungen die wir
nicht in deutschland spüren die wir
nicht in europa spüren sie werden
spürbar sein für die menschen im nahen
osten sie werden spürbar sein für die
menschen in afrika
gleichzeitig sehen wir in allen regionen
der welt dass das artensterben
vorantreibt und meine damen und herren
wir dürfen die augen nicht davor
verschließen dass die eine und die
andere herausforderung sich gegenseitig
wie katalysatoren befeuern können wir in
deutschland haben eine ethische und eine
praktische verantwortung aus diesen
gegensätzen eine einheit zu machen damit
wir welternährung und aber halt in
deutschland schaffen
und dazu
dazu hat die bundesregierung einen
dicken stein ins wasser geworfen mit den
vier milliarden für den natürlichen
klimaschutz und frau land gehe ich kann
mir vorstellen dass die verhandlungen
mit robert habeck um den anteil aus dem
energie und klimafonds nicht einfach
waren aber ganz im ernst hätte ich auf
einen von ihnen beiden betten müssen
meine stimme wer bei ihnen gewesen ich
kann mir gut vorstellen warum sie sich
so gut durchgesetzt haben herzlichen
glückwunsch dazu
kreislaufwirtschaft
früherer kreislaufwirtschaft den
wesentlichen ein umweltthema mit blick
auf vielen ländern aus denen unsere
rohstoffe kommen sehen wir dass in
diesen ländern nicht ganz unsere
umweltstandards eingehalten werden und
deswegen haben wir schon in der
vergangenheit immer wieder darauf
gedrungen dass rohstoffe öfter und
länger genutzt werden müssen seit dem
krieg in der ukraine kommen zwei neue
argumente zu dem thema
kreislaufwirtschaft dazu
menschenrechte und eine unabhängige
versorgungssicherheit und diesen
antworten anforderungen an die
kreislaufwirtschaft wird die
ampelkoalition gerecht werden
mit erweiterte hersteller verhandlung
mit einer besseren und vor allem
technologieoffenen finanzierung der
dualen systeme und auch mit dem
aktionsplan reparieren statt wegwerfen
der mit 19 millionen euro unterlegt ist
wo folgen wir dass sie den primär
ressourcen verbrauch zu reduzieren und
der ampel koalition wird dieses ziel
gelinge
das ist übrigens nicht nur ein gebot der
umwelt es ist auch ein gebot der
vernunft und der menschlichkeit
und gerade beim öl zeigt sich wie
wichtig die unabhängigkeit ist schon
heute müssen sich menschen in
deutschland zwischen tank und teller
entscheiden eine situation die wir von
noch ein jahr niemand hätte vorhersehen
können und dabei ist auch die mitte der
gesellschaft betroffen diejenigen die
jeden tag darum kämpfen sich und ihre
familie über wasser zu halten nur einen
geringen oder einen mittleren wohlstand
zu gewährleisten diesen menschen aus der
mitte der gesellschaft müssen wir helfen
der finanzminister christian lindner ins
gespräch gebrachte trank rabatt wird
jetzt mittlerweile wenigstens in
frankreich in italien umgesetzt das ist
ja auch schon mal ein erfolg aber ganz
ehrlich wir sind pragmatisch nach ob
tank rabatt energie geld oder mobilitäts
prämie die menschen wollen eine lösung
für den ganz konkreten probleme vor
denen sie heute stehen es ist wurscht
wie das kind heißt hauptsache die hilfe
kommt schnell und bürokratie ab dafür
ist die ampel gewährt wort gewählt
worden und das wird die ampel koalition
auch liefer und
auch ein ganz kleines thema so ein
bisschen in eigener sache
ganz ehrlich so hoch wie unsere energie
preise heute sind lohnen sich auch us-
und zwar entlang und in heizung und
hätten wir schon früher auf das thema
gesetzt werden wir vielleicht auch da
schon weiter es ist im moment eine tür
die offen ist es wäre schön auch die
ampel koalition würde durch diese tür
nehmen und auch den fuß perspektivisch
eine chance geben
ich habe ich habe eingangs gesagt dass
die ampel progressiv und pragmatisch in
der umwelt und verbraucherschutz politik
vorgehen wird sie wird auch effizient
und effektiv mit den geldern umgehen und
so finanzminister und die
umweltministerin haben dazu mit ihrem
haushaltsentwurf eine solide und eine
herausragende grundlage geschaffen den
feinschliff den feinschliff übernehmen
wir hier noch im parlament für die
umwelt und für die menschen in
deutschland
[Applaus]
der kollege klaus mack hält heute hier
seine erste rede und redet sie für die
cdu csu fraktion
der frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
liebe kollegen frau ministerin dieser
haushalt sieht weniger naturschutz vor
anstatt mehr die wahrheit ist ein
haushalt immer eine zahl der naturschutz
etat schrumpft und das in einem grünen
ministerium unlängst haben sie noch groß
verkündet dass ihnen der finanzminister
mehr mittel zugesteht was sieht
allerdings verschweigen dieses geld
fließt in andere bereiche das bedeutet
jetzt kein cent mehr für den natur und
den artenschutz und das obwohl sie beim
haushalt der vorgängerregierung größte
kritik geäußert haben der haushalt wäre
aus der zeit gefallen das sei im
klein-klein verhaftet ich frage sie wenn
sie als grüne umweltministerin jetzt
weniger geld für natur und artenschutz
ausgeben ich diese haushalt daneben noch
kleiner verhaftet dem naturschutz
erweisen sie so in jedem fall einen
bärendienst gefahr ministerin
das problem ist ein organisatorisches
ihnen fällen nämlich die grundlagen um
die erfolgreiche arbeit der letzten
jahre fortzuführen ihr ministerium wurde
schlichtweg ausgedünnt den klimaschutz
mussten sie anhang habig abgeben den
internationalen klimaschutz an frau
berbalk dabei wäre klima und naturschutz
aus einem guss notwendig es wäre große
chance gewesen das umweltministerium zu
einem transformation ist er ihm
auszubauen aber nein die ampel hat eine
ganzheitliche betrachtung verspielt die
grünen zulegen ihr eigenes ministerium
sie mussten federn lassen jetzt sofern
ihnen erhebliche mittel sodass sie beim
naturschutz hinter den hochgesteckten
erwartungen zurück bleiben wofür sie
dann im bundesamt für naturschutz und im
umweltbundesamt über 100 neue
personalstellen brauchen ist mir ehrlich
gesagt schleierhaft eine zielgerichtete
organisation eines bundes ministerium
sieht so jedenfalls nicht aus meine
damen und herren
das wäre aber notwendig um die
energiewende voranzubringen sie wollen
die genehmigungs dauer beim ausbau der
regenerativen energien halbieren da sind
wir dabei
11.000 megawatt windenergie stecken
derzeit im genehmigungsverfahren fest
damit könnte man nahezu siegen
großstädte wie hamburg versorgen und die
hälfte aller klagen sind auf den
artenschutz zurückzuführen größtenteils
werden übrigens diese von umwelt- und
naturschutzverbänden geführt es ist doch
leider häufig das grüne klientel vor ort
dass projekte blockiert verschleppt und
mit klagen gedroht ich war viele
bürgermeister der stadt bad wildbad und
zur windkraft projekt wurde über sechs
jahre lang blockiert wegen ein paar
fledermäusen und einem wespenbussard da
fragt man sich doch ob so ein vogel bei
über 90 prozent waldanteil bei uns im
schwarzwald keinen anderen baum findet
meine damen und herren
sie wollen jetzt einen paradigmenwechsel
die population soll künftig geschützt
worden und nicht mehr der einzelne vogel
das ist tatsächlich ein richtiger weg um
mit einem nationalen arten hilfsprogramm
soll das ganze abgefedert werden aber
nach berechnungen ihres eigenen
ministerium sind dazu mindestens 100
millionen euro jährlich notwendig wenn
ich mir aber ihren haushalt ansehe dann
verstecken sie dieses programm in diesen
nebulösen bundes naturschutz fonds und
in wahrheit sehen sie nicht mal 1,5
millionen euro vor des alten
hilfsprogramm vor das ist reine
augenwischerei sind als tiger gestartet
und als bettvorleger und sie werden
damit sicher nicht jenen vor ort
überzeugen die fledermäuse zählen und
die fahne des naturschutzes hoch halten
und
noch eine frage stelle ich mir bei
diesem haushalt sie sehen angst hat
100.000 euro für herdenschutz esel vor
ob das unsere weidetiere vor dem wolf
schützt möchte ich mehr als bezweifeln
ich glaube da wollen sie eher nach dem
sprichwort handeln im moment über eine
sache gras gewachsen ist kommt irgendein
es langfristig wieder runter allerdings
wächst über die berufs problematik
sehen sie endlich ein dass der wolf in
manchen regionen deutschlands zu einem
echten problem geworden ist last legen
sie für das monitoring einheitliche
kriterien vor der günstigen
erhaltungszustand der population wolf
ist längst erreicht deshalb sollte es
auch kein tabu mehr sein den wolf als
jagdbaren tiere auch um das
bundesjagdgesetz aufzunehmen es muss
jetzt schluss sein mit der
romantisierenden vorstellungen einzelner
tierschützer der wolf ist kein kuscheln
sondern ein raubtier also es gibt in
diesem haushalt doch viel nachzuarbeiten
nutzen sie die chance bei den
haushaltsberatungen im sinne des natur
und artenschutzes
nachzusteuern umzuschichten neu zu
justieren
notwendig wäre jetzt naturschutz mit
gesundem menschenverstand zu gestalten
und die aufgabe anzugehen
klimaschutz landwirtschaft umwelt
naturschutz mit dem menschen in einklang
zu stellen denn auch der mensch gehört
zur natur ich danke ihnen
ersten rede erst abgeordneter für die
cdu/csu-fraktion im deutschen bundestag
ist direkt gewählt in baden württemberg
unseren wahlkreis ist kalt
er hatte einiges hier zu kritisieren im
einzigen mann wenn sie das wort und für
umwelt naturschutz nukleare sicherheit
und verbraucherschutz erhöhen doch es
gibt grüne darauf
erwidern jetzt direkt nämlich stefan
menschen für die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe frau
ministerin vielen dank für die
vorstellung ihres haushaltes hier heute
im bundestag
wir alle stehen in diesen wochen unter
dem eindruck der ereignisse in der
ukraine
zwei wochen nach diesem ereignis bereits
hat die eu-kommission ein programm
vorgelegt unter dem stichwort repower eu
und das kann sich sehen lassen beim
gipfel von vers 11 erteilt haben die
staats und regierungschefs darauf bezug
genommen ein zentrales ziel es
abhängigkeiten zu beseitigen
abhängigkeiten insbesondere von russland
zu beseitigen
darum geht es meine damen und herren
widerstandsfähigkeit zu gewinnen
resilienz auch genannt und das gilt auf
allen ebenen jetzt und ist ein zentraler
punkt für alle unsere
ministerien und auch
das umweltministerium wird mit diesem
haushalt ganz wesentliche beiträge dazu
leisten und sehr geehrter herr mag ich
glaube sie haben bei ihrer analyse
schlicht und einfach den finanzplan für
das sondervermögen energie und
klimafonds
übersee klima klima und transformations-
von übersehen dann sehen sie dass dieses
haus in zukunft weit mehr
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten hat als in der
vergangenheit und das werden wir auch
ganz praktisch sehen es geht um moore es
geht um wälder es geht um mehrere
meeresschutz allein 90 millionen für die
beseitigung von altlasten aber auch für
das was zum beispiel durch die
versauerung der meere droht das ist
unsere nahrungsgrundlage das ist die
nahrungsgrundlage für milliarden
menschen auf der erde aber die vier
milliarden im klima- und
transformations- fonds die werden da
weit darüber hinaus hier eben auch
beiträge leisten um natürlichen
klimaschutz zu nutzen meine damen und
herren
kreislaufwirtschaft das ist effizienz
das heißt wir nutzen unsere rohstoffe so
dass sie möglichst effizient zur
anwendung kommen wir vermeiden den abbau
von neuen rohstoffen auch das macht uns
unabhängiger widerstandsfähiger
resilient weil wir diese rohstoffe dann
nicht einkaufen müssen beispielsweise in
russland meine damen und herren
das sind punkte das sind einige
beispiele die dieser haushalt liefert
und ich bin sicher wir werden aus diesem
ressort sehr nachhaltige sehr wichtige
beiträge sehen er hörte es geht genau in
die andere richtung der beschluss zur eu
sagt wir müssen massiv den umbau unserer
energieversorgung beschleunigen und um
unabhängig zu werden von
rohstoffimporten aus russland und dazu
leistet dieser haushalten wichtigen
beitrag meine damen und herren und es
war neulich auch die ausschussberatung
ich glaube dass die ministerin hier
wegweisende die dinge auf den tisch
gelegt hat und ich danke ihnen fürs
zuhören
[Applaus]
streng sein überträgt sich von einer
präsidentin auf die nächsten
dass das wort hat der kollege jürgen
braun für die aktiv wachsen
frau präsidentin liebe kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren hatte
die märkische energiewende wegen eines
tsunami in japan schon den charakter
einer absurden tragödie so wiederholt
sich heute vieles als traurige farce
landwirtschaftsminister erste mir
behauptet weniger fleisch essen wäre ein
beitrag gegen putin wörtlich frau
minister lemke verteidigt hier eine
linksradikale sekte mit dem real
satirisch treffenden namen letzte
generation die widerrechtlich deutsche
straßen blockiert und fleißige bürger an
ihrer arbeit hindern denn darum geht es
uns zur letzten generation zu machen zu
letzten menschen wie sie nietzsches
zarathustra beschrieb kein held und eine
herde jeder will das gleiche jeder ist
gleich wir haben das glück erfunden
sagen die letzten menschen und blinzeln
zitat ende
der haushaltsplanentwurf der gründlichen
die ampel ist ein sammelsurium an
absurditäten mit 625.000 euro wollen sie
im rahmen der
fußball-europameisterschaft 2024
unterschiedliche aktivitäten
umweltschutz bezogen unterstützen und
sie wollen jugend sport und jugend
umweltverbände in ihrem nachhaltigkeits
bezogenen engagement bestärken williams
fährt er jetzt noch gerade als modewort
was soll man darunter verstehen wollen
sie den nationalmannschaften recycelte
trikots aufzwingen oder wollen sie
lastenräder anschaffen die dann an
stelle von flugzeugen zur anreise
genutzt werden oder was meinen sie
überhaupt was meinen sie überhaupt mit
dem beitrag des fußballs zu mehr
nachhaltigkeit was haben umweltverbände
mit sportverbänden zu tun
das bundesumweltministerium wollte sich
eigentlich ganz anderen fragen zuwenden
als der nächsten em zum beispiel der
frage warum die eu die kernkraft für
nachhaltig hält deutschland aber wieder
mal einen sonderweg gehen wird
und auch der frage warum uns die schwarz
rot grün-gelbe altparteien riege durch
ihren kopflosen kernkraftausstieg
innerhalb von über 10 jahren völlig in
die abhängigkeit von russland
manövriert hat völlig in die
abhängigkeit der reinhardswald in
nordhessen märchenwald der brüder grimm
dieser legendäre deutsche wald wird
jetzt brutal abgeholzt gefördert von den
rücksichtslosen anhängern der klima
sekte in der schwarz grünen
landesregierung in hessen um angeblich
die welt zu retten um angeblich die welt
zu retten zerstören will
industrieanlagen wälder verschandeln die
landschaft
zerstören unsere blicke auf die natur
abbauen die horizonte artenschutz spielt
keine rolle mehr in der grün linken
ideologie der altparteien
rotmilane störche spechte fledermäuse
sie alle sind den deutschen regierung
egal wenn die lindt windkraft lobby ruft
naturschutz am ende das ist deutschland
heute
das findet für und frauen für die afg
funktioniert das thema atomkraft
ist in den letzten wochen hier
diskutiert worden die beiden häuser
nämlich bundeswirtschafts- und
klimaministerium
auf den krieg und für den fall eines
ausfalls russische energie womit wingst
ob die kernkraftwerke die in deutschland
noch laufen weiter genutzt werden sollen
beispielsweise das ergebnis längere
laufzeiten seien weder sinnvoll noch
vertretbar sagt beispielsweise auch die
grüne umweltministerium mindestens
listerine verzeihung steffi lemke sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen haben sie sich
schon einmal gedanken über ihren
einkaufswagen gemacht die anordnung der
griffe hat einfluss auf unser
konsumverhalten
griffe an der seite sorgen laut einer
studie dafür dass wir 25 prozent mehr
einkaufen das wissen unternehmen mit
sicherheit denn sie beschäftigen sich
mit dem verhalten von kundinnen und
kunden um dieses zu steuern und so ihre
gewinne zu maximieren
darum ist es wichtig zu erkennen wo die
selbstbestimmung der menschen in ihrem
konsum endet und sie geschützt werden
müssen
auch um auf neue marktentwicklungen
reagieren und richtige und die richtigen
politischen maßnahmen zu entwickeln sind
wir auf verlässliche erkenntnisse
angewiesen dafür brauchen wir die
wissenschaft es ist gut dass wir den
sachverständigenrat für
verbraucherfragen und das bundesnetzwerk
verbraucherforschung haben darauf lässt
sich aufbauen
jetzt wollen wir die verbraucher
wissenschaft weiterentwickeln wir wollen
eine breitere wissenschaftliche basis
durch ein bundesinstitut für
verbraucherforschung
wir alle sie und ich unsere eltern und
unsere kinder konsumieren
verbraucherpolitik betrifft also alle
menschen deshalb sollten wir endlich den
stellenwert zukommen lassen den sie
verdient in all ihren facetten
wie oft hören wir die schule vermitteln
nichts fürs leben und haben wir das
nicht auch selbst oft gedacht
hier setzt schulische verbraucherbildung
an schleswig holstein hat es vorgemacht
und verbraucherbildung als eigenes fach
in den lehrplan aufgenommen
denn auf nachhaltigkeit ernährung
digitales verträge oder finanzen
verbraucherthemen betreffen eben genau
das unser gesamtes leben und darauf
sollten kinder vorbereitet sein
natürlich sind in erster linie wir als
politik gefordert die menschen mit
wirksamen regeln und gesetzen zu
schützen trotzdem kommt es immer auch
auf die konsumierenden selbst und
deshalb ist verbraucherbildung so
wichtig umso mehr in einer konsum welt
die sich immer schneller verändert
ja schulbildung ist sache der länder
ein flächendeckendes vorankommen wäre
ich hier dennoch wünschenswert und
sinnvoll
ganz ohne möglichkeiten ist aber auch
der bund nicht so fördern wir bereits
das projekt verbraucher schulen ein
wunderbares projekt mit sehr motivierten
teilnehmenden damit es dauerhaft
bestehen kann müssen wir diese förderung
verstetigen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
verbraucherpolitik ist seit dieser
wahlperiode dem umweltministerium
angegliedert und das hat durchaus charme
ich bin davon überzeugt die entwicklung
zu einer nachhaltigen klimaneutralen
gesellschaft eine der herausforderungen
der nächsten jahre gelingt nur gemeinsam
mit den verbraucherinnen und
verbrauchern
und deshalb liegt eine große chance
darin wenn wir umwelt und
verbraucherpolitik stärker zusammen
denken
nehmen wir nun einmal unsere konsum und
wegwerfgesellschaft es kann doch nicht
sein dass produkte in der tonne landen
weil ersatzteile fehlen und sie nicht
repariert werden können das bereits
genannte und im koalitionsvertrag
verankerte recht auf reparatur ist mir
daher ein herzensanliegen
wenn die energiepreise wie aktuell durch
die decke gehen braucht es kurzfristig
erst einmal entlastungen für die
privaten haushalte
einige davon wurden von der
bundesregierung bereits auf den weg
gebracht andere werden folgen
auch energie sparen ist ein probates
mittel denn in fast jedem haushalt
stecken ungeahnte einsparpotenziale wer
schon einmal eine energieberatung in
anspruch genommen hat weiß wovon ich
rede
die verbraucherzentrale machen hier
tolle angebote sie werden derzeit
geradezu überrannt und
deshalb brauchen sie von uns noch mehr
unterstützung
meine damen und herren sie sehen von
gute verbraucherpolitik profitieren wir
alle ganz persönlich und gleichzeitig
auch die umwelt daran werde ich immer
wieder erinnern
[Applaus]
das wort hat uwe feiler für die cdu csu
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin wird
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
frau ministerin sie haben in ihrer rede
gerade den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien angesprochen im zusammenhang
mit dem artenschutz programm leider
haben sie in ihrer rede kein wort zu den
menschen gesagt die an diesen
photovoltaikanlagen die an diesen
windkraftanlagen leben müssen sondern
höre auf den artenschutz sind sie
reingegangen und so bekommen sie keine
akzeptanz für den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und
deswegen meine bitte deswegen meine
bitte oder aufforderung hier anders
vorzugehen anders zu argumentieren
sie haben viel über den haushalt gesagt
für das
für den klima- und umweltschutz und
der kollege markets angesprochen ihre
rede zum haushalt
2021 im kleinen verhaftet wenig
ambitioniert
dürftige leistung waren damals ihre
worte jetzt stellt sich die frage was
ist eigentlich jetzt anders was haben
sie mehr auf den weg gebracht und da
reicht ein blick in das nackte
zahlenwerk des einzel platz 16 und da
will ich als ein beispiel nennen die
förderung von maßnahmen zur anpassung an
den klimawandel
59 57 1 millionen euro das ist auf den
ersten blick ein aufwuchs von 37,5
millionen euro
aber wenn man dann mal genauer hinschaut
ist es genau der identische ansatz aus
dem jahr 2020 und das liegt daran dass
im jahre 2021 diese mittel aufgestockt
worden durch die konjunkturpakete des
jahres 2020 ist also nichts neues nichts
oben drauf es ist das was die
vorgängerregierung auch schon gemacht
hat und deswegen glaube ich ist das was
die vorgängerregierung in den jahren
zuvor gemacht hat doch einigermaßen
ambitioniert gewesen
auch
dass der von ihnen eben gerade
angepriesene zusätzliche bundes
naturschutz von den möchte ich auch kurz
erwähnen bisher hatten wir förderung
biologischer vielfalt 45 millionen euro
die einrichtung schutzwürdiger teile von
natur und landschaft 14 millionen euro
erprobung und entwicklungsvorhaben 4
millionen euro die augen renaturierung
schlug mit zehn millionen euro zu buche
der wildnis von 20 millionen euro
insgesamt 93 millionen euro
der neue bundes naturschutz vom im
einzelplan 16 hat genau 90 3 4 millionen
euro inhalt in ist also beim einfüllen
der verschiedenen schläuche des weines
in den neuen einzelnen schlauch der um
mit integriert wurde sind in der sogar
2,6 millionen euro daneben geflossen es
ist schlichtweg alter wein in einem
neuen schlauch auch nichts neues es ist
für also wenig ambitioniert und das
zieht sich eigentlich wie ein roter
faden durch den gesamten einzuplanen 16
wir haben kleinere umschichtungen wir
haben in einzelnen bereichen kürzungen
und zusätzliche maßnahmen und neue
maßnahmen wenn einzig und alleine durch
das sondervermögen und durch neue
schulden finanziert nichts anderes
und sie haben sie haben gesagt das
schafft mehr gestaltungsspielraum ist in
einer reden jetzt gefallen meine damen
und herren auch meine tochter mein sohn
meine enkelkinder möchten künftig noch
gestaltungsspielräume haben und deswegen
müssten diese schulden ja auch
irgendwann zurückgezahlt werden und sie
hängen mit ihrer haushaltspolitik mit
neuen schulden die gestaltungsspielräume
nachfolgender generationen 1
200 milliarden euro neuverschuldung
tendenz steigend ein ergänzungs haushalt
der
angekündigt es keinerlei
prioritätensetzung normalerweise müssten
sie meine damen und herren ihren
koalitionsvertrag auf dem tisch liegend
überarbeiten und prioritäten setzen das
ganze fehlanzeige
und wir sprachen von einer zeitenwende
meine damen und herren und diese
zeitenwende ja die ist tatsächlich
gegeben und ich möchte auch zwei punkte
noch kurz eingehen das ist zum einen die
ernährungssicherheit für deutschland für
europa und für die welt die sehe ich
aufgrund des krieges nämlich gefährdet
und da jetzt von stilllegungen von
flächen zu sprechen
da neue schutzgebiete auszuweisen
liebe frau ministerin da würde ich sie
bitte haben dass sie mit dem
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister gemeinsam
in brüssel aktiv werden und die
angedachten
flächenstilllegungen aus dem gast
strategieplan noch mal aussetzen das
wäre sinnvoll wir brauchen jetzt jeden
einzelnen quadratmeter in deutschland
zur lebensmittelproduktion und
wenn wir schon mal bewirtschaftung der
flächen sind möchte ich noch kurz an
sprechen das sind natürlich in
schutzgebieten jetzt auch schon
bewirtschaftungsauflagen für unsere
landwirte haben und da habe ich große
hoffnung auch richtung fdp die hier vor
mir sitzt dass dort auch noch einmal
überdacht wird gerade beim thema düngung
beim thema pflanzenschutz das in ihre
themen der letzten legislaturperiode
oder gewesen und auch da müssen wir noch
mal ran und entsprechend diskutieren wir
brauchen praxis
wir brauchen praxisorientierte lösungen
mit umwelt und landwirten gemeinsam
kooperationsmodelle das schild weiter
und als letzten punkt möchte ich auch
noch die waldbewirtschaftung ansprechen
dort ist es nämlich genauso sie meine
damen und herren von den grünen möchten
und auch das bundesumweltministerium
setzt auf
naturbelassenen wälder auf wildnis wir
von der cdu csu fraktion wollen eine
nachhaltige waldbewirtschaftung nach dem
motto schützen durch nützen wir wollen
natürlich auch keine alten
buchenbestände und eichenbestände
abholzt das will kein mensch aber eine
vernünftige bewirtschaftung unserer
wälder muss möglich sein wir brauchen
auch einen entsprechenden holzeinschlag
gerade auch für ihr programm was sie
aufgelegt haben nachhaltiges bauen mit
holz wo soll das ganze holz denn
eigentlich herkommen wenn wir unsere
wälder nicht mehr bewirtschaften und
auch wir haben es kurz gehört vorhin die
die ankündigung des uba
auch holz als energieträger halte ich
für enorm wichtig deswegen wir haben
viele fragen die noch offen sind wir
haben einige punkte über die dinge
diskutieren müssen ich freue mich auf
die beratungen und zum thema wolf habe
ich jetzt leider keine zeit vielen dank
[Applaus]
die letzte rede in dieser debatte
allerdings die erste für den kollegen
kommt aus der spd-fraktion von aktuell
wäre ja wirklich die letzte
porzellan
es war aber mir noch nicht der letzte
für heute an diesem tag
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen der demokratischen
fraktionen sehr gerne zuschauen
[Applaus]
ich halte heute man erste rede im
deutschen bundestag
und es ist mir eine ehre und ein
privileg die menschen aus meinem
wahlkreis i vertreten zu dürfen
und es freut mich
und ist freut mich dass sie ist ein
bundestag tun darf der die bevölkerung
unseres landes in ihrer diversität
widerspiegelt und ich denke dies freut
uns alle bis auf diejenigen die extrem
rechts sitzen und auch zu denken
wir alle hier im haus haben in einer
zeit der krisen verantwortung übernommen
kein bundestag
stand vor dem parallelen
herausforderungen denen wir uns aktuell
stellen müssen die korona krise die eine
gefahr für unsere gesundheit aber auch
für unser gesellschaftliches miteinander
darstellt die energieverteuerung die
sehr viele menschen und unternehmen in
bedrängnis bringt und der überfall auf
die ukraine der die geopolitische lage
in der welt komplett verändert hat hinzu
kommt der menschengemachte klimawandel
diese drohende katastrophe ist deutlich
abstrakter als eine pandemie
energiepreise oder krieg das macht sie
aber nicht weniger gefahr der damen und
herren
ich komme aus dem ruhrgebiet bei uns
wurde mit dem hochwasser im juli 2021
aus der abstrakten gefahr des
klimawandels eine konkrete gefahr für
leib und leben selbst wenn bei uns
anders als in anderen landesteilen keine
personenschäden zu betrauern waren aber
diese katastrophe hat uns gezeigt und
vor augen geführt dass die folgen des
klimawandels längst vor unseren
haustüren angekommen sind und in dieser
nacht sind an der ruhr ganze existenzen
wortwörtlich den bach runtergegangen
deshalb ist es richtig dass die
bundesregierung den klimaschutz und den
erhalt unserer natürlichen
lebensgrundlagen in den mittelpunkt
ihres handelns stellt der heydt der
natürlichen co2 speicher der erhalt der
biodiversität sowie die stärkung der
kreislaufwirtschaft und abfallvermeidung
alles themenfelder in denen sich die
klimafrage mit entscheidet und alles
themenfelder die frau bundesministerin
von angesprochen hat von den aktuellen
krisen ist die drohende klimakatastrophe
die weitreichendste und wir brauchen
dringend lösungen lösung die eine
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz haben
akzeptanz die wii nur durch anreize und
sicherheit für die menschen erreichen
denn unsere art zu leben und zu
wirtschaften muss auf den prüfstand
unser ganzes land muss sich ändern
im ruhrgebiet kennen wir veränderungen
früher hieß das bei uns mal
strukturwandel der strukturwandel im
revier bedeutete vor allem der wegfall
gut bezahlter jobs den verlust der
finanziellen handlungsfähigkeit vieler
kommunen und das verschwinden ganzer
industriezweige das sind alles dinge mit
denen die städte an der ruhr heute noch
zu kämpfen haben meine damen und herren
und wir müssen aus den fehlern der
vergangenheit lernt ist dieses mal
besser machen und alle menschen dabei
mitnehmen
die ampel ist eine zukunfts koalition
wir sorgen dafür dass ökologie und
ökonomie sich nicht länger
widersprechenden in unserem land wir
sorgen dafür dass die menschen auch
morgen gut und sicher in diesem land
leben können ohne raub an unserem
planeten zu betragen und wir als spd
garantieren dabei dass sich unsere
klimapolitik jede und jeder leisten kann
denn wir garantieren sicherheit im
wandel meine damen und herren
den vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf steht
viel richtig ist und ich freue mich auf
die beratung im ausschuss vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
es wäre ja für die spd das letzte wort
hatte in diesem einzelplan er ist direkt
gewählte abgeordnete hatte jetzt hier
einiges rede kommt dass
nordrhein-westfalen
und seinen wahlkreis ist